lted raclette cheese from Switzerland
with cranberries and walnuts let's the
stand specialty
how about chipped sweet potatoes and
avinash schnitzel burger and for dessert
a praline mousse or carrot cake or
chocolate muffins vegan burgers are on
vogue to this market in Berlin shows
there's more to German fast food than
sausage and fries this is a vegan
shawarma I think it tastes better than a
regular one
schnitzel burger is delicious and really
original the portions aren't that big
but the point is to eat a variety of
things you don't come here to fill your
stomach for cheap but it's certainly
worth the money among the regular
vendors is Fabien gebet a trained chef
who grew tired of the same old work in
restaurants since 2012 he's been
travelling the length and breadth of
Germany with his food truck main
advantage of a food truck is that it's
mobile you can see where a certain food
goes down best most will be unvoiced my
neck will serve as a voice das bus is
unbeaten if it turns out it's just not
working out at the Jazz Festival then I
might go to a heavy metal event he got
the idea from when he lived in Canada
where pulled pork is a culinary favorite
Fabien then fine-tuned his own take the
meat source straight from the farmer is
slow-cooked for 20 hours in a water bath
little part the meats really tender and
the combination with red cabbage is
fabulous I had the barbecue orange sauce
and it was delicious
but the classic from across the pond is
served with mashed potato and a real
German style side braised red cabbage
with Apple customers can choose for favi
ons homemade sauces the quality comes at
a price
7 euros apportion our experience shows
that people are willing to pay the price
if they're looking for something new but
still with that street food character
mobile fast food joints are commonplace
in the streets of the u.s. in Germany
you might not see them on every street
corner but they're slowly catching on
here - sometimes I don't understand the
food truck people they must really love
good food because it's like they're
exploiting themselves they've got their
stand rental to pay and then they're
here for five or six hours in all kinds
of weather I think you need a lot of
commitment in North America in Germany
you can't just set up your stand any old
place it's far easier testa VLEs or
indeed special markets like this one in
Berlin
this book about to hit the market is an
illustrated tribute to the food truck
scene in Germany and neighboring
countries there's a fabulous range in
content and names to the food Mobile's
range from ice cream vans to car trunks
what they have in common is dedication
and imagination also featured is the
buns mobile and El Dorado for burger
fans
Pablo Serrano scene is continually
updating his range of recipes his menu
even as a burger made of lobster he
makes everything himself including the
buns even the truck has a unique story
of its own it was the food truck from
the US Army they were it was brought by
the US Army in 86 I think and and they
brought it just to make food for the
army and when the wall came down they
left Germany and the truck they left the
truck as well in Germany when he's not
serving customers the Canadian cook is
busy servicing the truck we're out
buying ingredients it's a labor of love
we always wanted to create like simple
foods because we used to work a lot with
little high-end restaurant where you
always deal with like like minimal stuff
and like high products super expensive
so wanted to have something simple that
you eat after work like a late shift
snack good like good fast food well done
you know food trucks might not yet be
competition for old school sausage and
Fries joints order no kabob stands but
they are proving a hit with the younger
generation